[Laughter]
foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night and we're doing our thing
like we usually do on Friday night
hopefully everybody can hear us yeah it
looks like the microphone's on right
yeah okay sometimes it turns itself off
it's just randomly I don't really know
why yeah we're gonna do a pre-game show
we're going out tonight
yeah it's Memento Mori
so we gotta go out to the club evening
so as long as we're done by 8 8 30
because we don't actually it doesn't
even open till 10 so we don't actually
even have to leave till 9 30. I already
got my clothes picked out I already got
all that kind of she's gotta do her
makeup yeah I'm gonna do the makeup over
again yeah I had put on this makeup
earlier for this show and I recorded a
video earlier this afternoon too but I
just did it like real quick and I like
to do like more
more elaborate and more long-lasting
[ __ ] if I'm gonna go out you know what
I'm saying yeah like with primer and
everything I'll either wear this or
something real close to this yeah I may
or may not wear this shirt we'll see
I don't think I've ever wore this shirt
there maybe I have
I don't yeah I don't think you have not
that I remember but you know I don't
really remember I go there my wife
beaters actually
I don't even remember what I wear there
most of half of the time so much less
what other people are wearing
you're saying my beard looks good thank
you
yeah freaking bent I've been trimming it
trying to get that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
it'll work out you should be Ming the
merciless yeah like me for Halloween
yeah his [ __ ] was even [ __ ] crazier
though his is it's pointed and then he's
got two [ __ ] big long whiskers that
come out you know two big you know the
ends of his mustache they go out [ __ ]
four inches that would take years to
grow well you would have to grow you
could do it with fake hair and it would
be crazy yeah
he's got that [ __ ] all [ __ ] you don't
want it for real because it's like it
would go in your mouth like every time
you tried to every time you were
sleeping it would go in your mouth every
time you try to eat a little triangle
here and then he's got that [ __ ]
disappointed and he really Aura your
tastes are too dangerous
every time I see [ __ ] like that in
movies it's like I always think like how
cool it looks but then I think what
about that person's day-to-day life
totally impressive like I said it's
totally impractical I was just I don't
know why I just thought of this but I
was thinking of um that Mystery Science
Theater episode where they talked about
Merlin's shop of magical wonders yeah
and the old like Merlin and he had like
this really big long like white beard
and white uh hair and everything like
that and I think it was Servo that said
have a feeling that his shower drain is
always clogged
yeah and I was like yeah exactly only an
emperor could have Ming's mustache and
and have that [ __ ] [ __ ] practical
because he's got a whole pit crew taking
care of his ass doing his nails and [ __ ]
doing his wardrobe he doesn't have to
pick out his own clothes just every day
they got some [ __ ] badass Imperial
outfit for him to wear and [ __ ] Lord
over people and he just like stands
there while they while they put it on
him
red uniforms of red satin uniforms with
a black and gold trim sitting there
eating [ __ ] olives or whatever it is
why his daughter's getting tortured okay
continue the torture [ __ ] yeah olives
though ew you look like black olives
weren't they I don't know your little
black balls he was eating them I think
maybe they were Whoppers
play this little mountain
if I remember correctly they were little
black balls or bonds which may have
actually I don't know if they looked
into it that much in mind just yeah he's
eating little black things little black
both but little black balls that him the
Chinese Emperors Woody were little black
balls of [ __ ] Mercury
remember those [ __ ] yeah yeah so
maybe that's what you know how'd that
work out for them didn't work out good
for [ __ ] sure Juan D it was a little
black ball that they ate it was like a
little Whopper piece of candy and into
the center of it was [ __ ] Mercury
drive you crazy but they thought it made
you immortal they thought it was Viagra
too
that you'd be able to have sex with a
bunch of women spoiler alert it's not
drove him crazy yeah well
Danny Rowling said earlier that there
was a uh that crussell has his own brand
of wine we'll check it out that we
should probably yeah we should we should
do like a whole show
across will see it what's it called like
it should be called Crustle wine it's
called crustal sphere nectar of the cups
or nectar of the crustless
I kind of like that actually yeah that's
a portal the portal to the [ __ ]
heavens
if that's not what it's called it should
be yeah
John Gore said you know they dubbed Over
The Flash Gordon actor's voice because
it was Major drama between you and Dino
DiLaurentis yeah I can't talk about that
that's not the original actor's voice
but you can't really tell I know yeah
yeah it doesn't look completely strange
you know what I mean I didn't notice it
as a kid I didn't either and actually I
probably wouldn't have noticed it if
somebody hadn't like pointed it out and
usually I notice yeah dubbing but you
know it's a great movie you know what I
mean um I remember and I saw it in the
theater probably about four times when
it came out
and
I didn't like it as much as Star Wars
but it fit right along with Star Wars in
a way uh there were certain things about
it that I liked better it was it was it
had more it had more it was more sexual
which Star Wars didn't have that it was
[ __ ] very G-rated this was definitely
PG today it would probably be PG-13 I
would think
um because there were sex and Drug
references throughout the Flash Gordon
Flash Gordon yeah I imagine it would
probably PG-13 PG-13 they didn't have
that rating
but um
um I liked it in a day and and I was
pissed that a sequel never came out
because they were they set it up for a
sequel at the end
the only thing I didn't like about it
was um
the Lizard Man costumes I didn't like
them
you know it's a definitely a rubber suit
and the guy's eyes were seeing through
the mouth yeah but they they didn't hide
that fact which is kind of like a weird
you know it's just weird artistic
decision they could just make the
argument it's like well it's not a
costume that's just what those aliens
look like yeah they look like a man in a
rubber suit yeah
with the eyes inside the mouth which is
some crazy [ __ ] they'd have that in a
probably in a
in a Flash Gordon comic book
but it didn't look that good on film
now if you a lot of a lot of times then
I saw it like an extra a [ __ ] ton of
extra times on um like HBO on CRT
televisions before HD and it looked a
lot crappier
but if you see it on Blu-ray on a good
television that's a lot closer to what
it looked like in theater and it looked
really good in theater the costumes are
super high quality the materials a lot
of handcrafted stuff it looks really
good and you didn't get that effect when
you saw it on CRT television so its
reputation actually kind of went down
when it went when it hit VHS and and
cable but in the theater it looked great
aside from the Lizard Man costumes I
didn't like those
and certain
there were certain effects that didn't
really come across too well even for the
era like the uh
the Birdman flying sequences didn't
didn't really look good uh enough well
the green screen [ __ ] back then was
always was always kind of shitty well
that's not exactly what I'm talking
about the the backgrounds looked really
psychedelic and really Vivid on the big
screen what I was talking about is that
that obviously their wings were not
flapping they were not flapping hard
enough to [ __ ] make those dudes fly
you know uh they were definitely solid
and it's just
but they were just doing what they could
I think I would have animated them
somehow with
I don't know
stop motion maybe or just actually have
the guys go through the air but then
somehow superimposed like
animated Wings over them but they just
didn't have that that kind of technology
or that time that much time I think to
put in that movie
it did achieve
what it set out to do though it did
accurately [ __ ] accurately portray
The Source material
that's that's what's that's what Flash
Gordon was
an outer space cereal
that did not involve outer space because
there was no space in space in Flash
Gordon it was just endless sky
endless Sky it was a space it was an
outer space where you could go out on
the wing of a [ __ ] spaceship and
still be able to breathe and this
spaceship had wings
so there was no space in space
and they
because you know it was written in a
time where they people didn't have a
good grasp of what outer space was
but
the movie kind of brought that concept
up to date they went through the
Imperial vortex
and on the other side of the vortex was
the dimension
where [ __ ] existed and like the
Imperium and [ __ ] and it didn't have
space it didn't have a the Blackness of
space it was just endless sky
and planets that were just like pieces
of planets sometimes like a little
planetoid or a round sphere and then
there was an up and down to everything
there wasn't
any of this nonsense like spherical
planets that had gravity didn't have any
of that
and that's what the source material was
so
it was a very early comic book movie and
it did it did a good job
Danny Rowling said like the lizard suit
and Terror train yeah I was kind of
thinking maybe sleestax
which is crazy because Land of the Lost
was like super low budget yeah but the
sleeve Stacks looked a lot better than
the lizard men from man I really like
this Lee Stacks I don't know why but but
you weren't supposed to take Flash
Gordon seriously
you know it was
entertainment
well period That's True of everybody
yeah I know some people take them too
seriously The Source material wasn't
to be taken seriously Kevin Smith said
bangs look good thank you very much I
decided Jenny's Hair that's her natural
hair yeah this is my actual hair yeah
today well I don't know it's just for
some reason
we I I was experimenting with because I
like the wigs that are straight down and
don't have bangs and I was like oh well
maybe I'll grow my bangs out and I was
growing out my undercut and I was just
kind of waiting for it all to be like
one length like Morticia
but then I was just like I was like I
don't know like the more I looked at it
I was like I don't know I want my bangs
back I just think I look better with
bangs and I thought to myself I have so
many wigs that don't have bangs so it's
like if I want to not have bangs one day
I'll just put a [ __ ] wig on you know
what I'm saying or I can just like comb
the bangs back if I'm really into it but
honestly I kind of I I'm I'm glad to
have them back because I I really think
I look better with bangs but you know
what I mean yeah that's what I think
anyway there's some somebody in the
comment section is talking about
just camping last night and listening to
YouTube on my cell phone heard you say
in her doctors examined her and after
she died turned out she she turned out
to be a virgin that's all I heard I
don't think I think he's talking about
you we weren't talking about we weren't
talking about Queen Victoria though
because she had nine kids yeah
it'd be pretty hard to have nine kids
have you ever heard a virgin yeah so
um I'm not it might have been one of my
videos that was like a true crime thing
or something like that I'm not really
Victoria was a virgin
she had nine kids though yeah I don't
know she had nine kids yeah
I thought it was that other queen that I
thought it was Elizabeth the first that
everybody called the Virgin Queen I
don't know even though I don't think she
was a virgin either but Victoria for
sure wasn't she had a whole bunch of
kids she hated having kids but she did
she had a bunch Colin Higgins ass wasn't
Star Wars heavily influenced by Flash
Gordon among other things uh yeah what
happened was is that
George Lucas wanted to to make Flash
Gordon but he couldn't afford the
licensing so he um kind of rebooted his
own version of it and you noticed Star
Wars
later on
um he didn't you know evidently he
didn't have a lot of money
um later on
Dino DiLaurentis secured the rights and
I think he maybe he may have had the
rights at the time Lucas was looking for
it you guys you may have to check on
that
and and he couldn't he couldn't get his
hands on him the price was too high so
in some way in in technically
the um
the dno to the rentus
Flash Gordon was not a Star Wars rip-off
Star Wars was rip Star Wars was a ripoff
of a [ __ ] Flash Gordon
uh and that was kind of like before the
dino DiLaurentis version had come out
uh dino DiLaurentis Studios man I liked
him they they were hit and miss but they
had some good Sci-Fi Classics man dude
the original Dune was a dino flick
for some reason they never really could
get the market and the product correct
but
those movies still are fun to watch
they're and they
were a nightmare to make there's a lot
of problems and going over budget you
know with that that studio just could
not run a tight ship
um and it went out of business
eventually
but man they made a lot of good movies a
lot of cool flicks were Dino flicks I
mean they made a lot of [ __ ] once a lot
of [ __ ] once right that's okay yeah but
they have some real if you make a lot of
stuff like some of it's gonna be yeah
they have some real Classics they had
some real Classics but even the classics
[ __ ] bombed most of them at the box
office
they retroactively became classics
yeah we were talking about that the
other day yeah hey Dave what's up hello
you two Jen looking fire thank you very
much yeah like I was saying I'm glad I'm
back to the banks I feel more like
myself again I was feeling like I didn't
really look like myself without bangs
um yeah Elizabeth the first was called
the Virgin Queen yeah that's what I
thought now somebody says Buck Rogers
was The Flash Gordon rip-offer was the
other way around it may have been the
other way around I think Buck Rogers
might have been the original but don't
quote me on how old is but is Buck
Rogers because a lot of the like stuff
like that like Flash Gordon and stuff
like that started out as Comics or C or
old cereals like back in the very very
early days of film I know Flash Gordon
did and then I thought Buck Rogers did
as well but I don't remember I don't
know which one came first I think Buck
Rogers might have come first
um at least on the in comic books I
don't know the screen because they had
both of those I think it was Buster crab
it wasn't a buster crab did Buck Rogers
or was he the one that did Flash Gordon
uh I can't remember man yeah he did one
of those he did one of them but they
were he was in a lot of those yeah and
both of those series
sucked basically in certain ways uh
technically they sucked but they were
fun for the kids that were watching them
at the time they were for kids they were
taking them to places that you know that
they had never been in exotic locations
and Flash Gordon was the edgier one I
remember seeing him as a kid
and if you buy the Flash Gordon Blu-ray
it comes with the first
um
two episodes or one episodes of of Flash
Gordon and it is basically the movie
real close
um and there were [ __ ] Wild
undertones sexual undertones and Drug
overtones undertones of Satanism and
you know like the the opening credits
show this like forearmed demonic [ __ ]
god with its arms moving and in its and
fire and in its hands there's basically
nude women dripping out of his hands you
know dancers in [ __ ] clear leotards
and
basically are slipping each other
Mickeys and [ __ ] Sex Potions so you
know princess Aura can get some dick off
a [ __ ] Flash Gordon and
her dad knows and this is [ __ ] wild
[ __ ] man it's 20s you know pre-haze code
[ __ ] and this is like children's
material
basically well the thing about it even
if you see I kind of feel like even up
until the haze code came into play
because they didn't it came into play
but then they didn't really start
cracking down on it I feel like it's a
little bit later but you have to think
too that some of those drugs were kind
of still illegal so you can still sort
of talk like [ __ ] I even remember some
maybe like Looney Tunes like cartoons
and stuff like that from the 30s and 40s
that talked about
that that talked about like well people
Mickey's and yeah and like Dexys and
stuff like that which like I said so
which that was a little bit later
knockout drops yeah like all that kind
of stuff so if you think about it now
it's just it's kind of like wow [ __ ]
it's horrifying but yeah it's just like
it was
I was watching um God I can't remember
what it was but it was like some short
from
it's probably a Mystery Science Theater
because that's when I see all those the
old shorts and stuff but they were doing
one
or maybe it was a maybe it was a Charlie
Chaplin movie where there was just
somebody like selling cocaine in the
street like big sign that says cocaine
yeah
but it was that's wild [ __ ] man and
[ __ ] this is for
people in their early teens teenagers
you know [ __ ] eight nine-year-old
boys are watching this and
got the sexy [ __ ] alien princess Aura
of telling her dad no I want him as my
Royal concert consort you know and he's
like okay you know we're gonna hook that
up for you you know we'll you know just
give him these knockout drops [ __ ]
you know in This Love Potion that's what
it is giving this love potion he won't
be able to resist you after that that
kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean it's
just like that's wild [ __ ] when you
think about it in the context of the
time
yeah we can kind of see how parents
would be like wait a minute hold on what
is this they were roofie in each other
[Laughter]
when he's talking about Hollywood she's
running around basically half nude for
the time
yeah you know which is uh leotards with
[ __ ] skirts and kind of just pasties
over her nipples and wild [ __ ]
headdresses and [ __ ] you know and Ming
looks just like
Ming from Flash Gordon you know the
maximum side of side of me he looked
like that it's just cheaper you know
lower budget then basically the same
outfit and Heritage Dollar Store version
yeah
the budget was real low on the TV
version
it wasn't TV no they showed them as
before the movies like yeah they showed
them before like little cereals or
chapter please yeah but in the 70s when
I was a kid they'd have them on local
television
in California you can on Saturday
Saturday afternoon you can watch them
I'm trying to think of the one that they
because they did
um
Mystery Science Theater did a bunch of
the shorts too like sometimes they'd
show like one of the cereals like
chapters like before some of the movies
I know they did the Phantom creeps which
had Bella Lugosi in it and his little
exploding spiders oh my God why did
everything go blurry why'd it go blurry
what the [ __ ]
come on
okay that was weird
Tom's moving around too much I guess
I don't know but they also did another
one that was kind of sci-fi the [ __ ] was
the name of that thing
it was the one with crash core again
maybe some maybe somebody will remember
but he was like a boxer I want to say
a boxer or a wrestler but then also he
had a sideline as like a space Explorer
or something I don't remember it's been
a long time since I've seen him the ice
cubes are looking a little small even
though they're sent on high we had a
problem with the ice maker
it's working now though but yeah it
wasn't making ice
and um there's some mechanical things in
there it's got to move
but you can't really see them so I took
him down took it downstairs in the big
sink and look started spraying and the
little ice cube maker tray that kind of
moves in there was totally
slimed up with [ __ ]
mildew that we were drinking ice out of
it but I didn't know I couldn't see it
somehow it was
keeping it from moving so I had to blast
all that out of there it's good for you
know that's good for you yeah well
there's little filters and [ __ ] but
you're cycling water even though it's
filtered water that we're using it's
just uh
you got water out and exposed you know
what I mean or it's getting wet up in
there it's not the water you're putting
in it's stuff that's splashing up on the
surf up on the ceilings of this damn
machine that'll start to kind of get old
it's a place where bacteria could grow
but we're drinking that [ __ ] but now
that I know I can stay on top of it yeah
for some reason it's it's uh it's making
funny shaped ice cubes we'll see
well you know as long as they're ice
cubes that's fine yeah like I said it's
[ __ ] Florida everything is damp at
all times I feel like I have to I have
my little disinfecting wipes and I have
to do them like every day or two like
around the sink because you know mold
will start to grow around the [ __ ]
sink if you just like leave stuff wet
everything's just damp all the time it
sucks grandpar said in high school The
Love Potion we frequently used was
called Bartles and James yeah do they
still make that [ __ ] I don't know man I
remember the commercials for it like
more than anything I don't I don't know
if I ever had any I probably did but I
remember the commercials more than
anything
they're talking about Halloween ends
yeah how is that I kind of want to I
couldn't even believe because we haven't
been to the movie theater movie theater
in so long and I was like God there's
like so much [ __ ] that I want to see and
so I looked on there to see what was
playing and yeah there's like five
[ __ ] horror movies that I that are
out that I want to see I can has anybody
seen that movie smile because that looks
pretty good that looks pretty cool
actually yeah Isabella Buster was Buster
crab Flash Gordon or was he Buck Rogers
I forgot
Buster crab I think might have been
Flash Gordon
once I poke she called me what's the
matter yeah
what's up she came up next to the chair
went
she wants me to say hi to her what's up
you want to come up here do you want to
come up in Daddy's lap she's biting me
now what you buying why are you biting
why she's mad no yeah she wants me to go
throw why are you mad she wants me to
throw I threw today throw stuff and she
catches it out of the air
oh you want to play catch uh
she's like yeah come out here and throw
it bro please either that or she's like
come over here and be our ush me yeah I
have to spell it because she knows what
the word is
she's super smart
she she has a pretty good vocabulary she
knows what we're talking about yeah
that's why I try not to say like the
words because she'll be like raw yeah
hey Grandma says smile is good that
movie legit [ __ ] me up and I'm sure
Jenny you're gonna get terrified now see
now I really want to see it it looks
really really cool like from the
trailers
and I think Barbarian is still playing
my replacement uh frames and terrifier
too yeah yeah is playing at the theater
maybe we should go see that tomorrow
okay that would be super fun do you have
a few busterman Splash Gordon okay yeah
didn't you do Tarzan too maybe was he
also Tarzan which one which one was um
what was um
which one was uh Buck Rogers was Buck
Rogers a copy of Flash Gordon was Flash
Gordon a copy of Buck Rogers for some
reason I wanted to see if Flash Gordon
might have not been the original I think
Buck Rogers might have been the original
but it's
been so long since I've even thought
about that subject but how those two
relate
I remember that I was surprised that it
was so I was thinking that Flash Gordon
might have been the copy of Buck Rogers
I think
now I'm kind of curious I have to look
it up because it was two different
companies competing
and they need one of those and then they
came up with a but I don't remember
which one which one was which
Danny Rowling said Halloween ends is
worth watching and way better than
scream 2022. yeah that kind of I I
remember it said Halloween and sucked he
says don't watch it don't watch he told
me not well there's a bunch of other
movies that I would go see I liked
Halloween kills
um you know it wasn't fantastic but I
thought it was like pretty good but
there's a bunch of other movies that I
would watch before that you know what I
mean I want to see smile I want to see
Barbarian I want to see terrifier too so
at least those three I would see before
Halloween ends you know what I'm saying
yeah
Ben's talking about Battlestar Galactica
yeah Battlestar Galactic what Galactica
was also kind of similar to Star Wars
the other ones it was it Battlestar
Galactica was a Star Wars rip-off
um Star Wars was popular and they needed
to have some kind of a television series
that was Star Wars like so they came out
with Battlestar
and I remember liking it as a kid with
the cylons and everything the original
Battlestar Galactica
but you could tell it was a California
series there was a lot of California in
it and the outdoor scenes you know they
were on other planets you can tell like
yeah that's out in [ __ ] San
Bernardino you know just [ __ ] like that
you could you could you could recognize
it as California
and it never really kind of had the
never really kind of had the oomph I
mean they didn't really have a Darth
Vader per se Baltar wasn't scarier I
don't think he wasn't for me he wasn't a
serious villain I actually kind of like
Lucifer the damn
that evil robot that they had with the
[ __ ] the evil Cylon robot and I
thought that was kind of cool
but
it didn't have a good enough feeling I
think that's the problem with the old
Battle Star Galactica it didn't have a
compelling villain
but it looked good man I had the [ __ ]
I would buy I was buying the Cylon toys
I had the [ __ ] Viper
that could shoot the Rockets out of the
front with the little pilot I had the
damn Cylon [ __ ]
fighter ship with the [ __ ] it was
like a flying saucer that opened up they
had good toys for it I was buying it as
a kid they even had little action
figures that would come out
little forearmed aliens and forearms of
[ __ ] insectoid things and
Starbucks and cylons and [ __ ] I think
some of them were even 12 inch figures
kind of like uh Star Wars The Big Star
Wars 12-inch dolls they go they weren't
action figures they were dolls but you
know let's go this time yeah they're
dolls they're dolls okay that was the
marketing thing where it's like well we
can't call them dolls because then boys
yeah like that was what for the GI Joe
dolls right yeah yeah they're so dolls
that's what battle star the original
Battle Star had it in its event it in
his pocket is that the toys are pretty
good they were pretty good
um
I saw Disney's uh a black hole and I
liked it as a kid I liked it
they didn't have enough toys for it
um or I would have bought them I I had
some models of Vincent
and I think I had a model of
Maximilian the other robot
but there wasn't really what anywhere
you could go with the black hole it
wasn't open-ended enough it wasn't like
Star Wars
you knew that it was a one and done
story basically
I'm trying to think of another one
that didn't quite have the toys that was
too old when it came out but
Dune they came out with a toy line
they were kind of substandard in a way
in terms of quality they weren't as good
as a Star Wars toy
then they came too late I wouldn't have
bought them I was too old by the time
that that [ __ ] came out
but the Dune could have been something
it could have if it had a stronger toy
line
the problem was is that the Dune the
theme of the original Dino De Laurentiis
Dune was pretty adult kids couldn't see
that's what I'm saying it wasn't really
like aimed toward children yeah so I
mean the thing about that is like that's
kind of like a moot point nowadays
because obviously they're going to make
Collectibles for any movie like that
because they are assuming that adults
collectors are gonna buy them which they
usually do rather than kids but yeah
like back then you can see why they
didn't do it because Dune wasn't
marketed toward children no they had a
towing line they did I know they did but
it's like it wasn't really marketing it
wasn't it didn't really make it
because kids didn't see it yeah I think
it was damn near R-rated I think if I
remember correctly
Dune
um
the thing is is that if you were smart
enough to buy those
Dune toys when they came out
you'd be wealthy because they're worth a
lot of money especially if they're still
in the package
I mean I think just a dune action figure
this you know for 400 bucks if it's
sealed in a package in the little
booster and they had vehicles and
everything so and um
they didn't make a lot of stuff but they
did make stuff and if you if you had
them if you have any of them and there's
in package they're worth a lot of money
even though they're not in package but
you but if they're in package [ __ ]
they're worth a lot
collectors will buy them it'd be a
bidding war
see you later Dave probably going to
mannequins I imagine we're actually
we're going to Barbarella we're going to
Barbara's for Memento Mori if you
haven't been to that man go check it out
it's pretty good
yeah kind of more exclusive crowd the
public isn't there a lot of stuff goes
down in the parking lot you can kind of
bring your own beer you can bring your
own yeah it's like a parking lot but
yeah yeah and then you go up there you
go out there and uh you can bring booze
in your car yeah have a little uh you
know yeah tailgate party yeah you go out
there and uh you know smoke things yeah
it's like a private it's like a private
golf park
you evidently [ __ ] some of them cars
out there in the parking lot bouncing up
and down every now yeah I could see that
well like I said there's nobody else
around yeah nobody else out there that's
the thing no no Norm he's gonna show up
they don't know about I don't even know
about the place it's like even if they
do it's like I don't think anybody's
gonna wander that far afield because
there's nothing else around right
there's not even any restaurants or
right it's out in the it's out in the
dam it's out in the industrial park
Industrial Park it's in a warehouse
District where everything's closed so
everything around it like for a mile in
all directions is closed already
uh next match of media said do you guys
remember a really [ __ ] up movie in
this 1970s called Ruby yes I do I think
that's going to be my Halloween feature
this year you know what's weird I just
saw that movie riff tracks did a version
of it and it's on 2B or at least it was
like a few weeks ago
and that was I think the first time I
had seen it I wanted to watch it because
that's one with Piper Laurie right was
it Piper Laurie on that yeah I actually
kind of I actually quite like that movie
yeah it is pretty [ __ ] up but you know
Ben's talking about Star Trek too yeah
the thing is though is that
Star Trek the Original Series did have a
toy line
I saw it all the time as a kid in the
70s
and never pulled the trigger on it your
mom's always with he says buy something
pick something out and I'd be looking at
the Star Trek toys
and I and there'd be like seven or eight
and they they were little
articulated action figures probably
about that tall and they had clothing on
them you had Kirk Spock you had a couple
of the other characters like they might
have had bones and maybe Uhura and and
and and something like maybe Sulu but
then you had the Gorn
and I was always looking at that damn go
get the Goran and kirking yeah there was
a Gorn and then there was that other
damn white thing with the horn on his
head what was it called the collar or
the [ __ ] whatever whatever the [ __ ]
that was it yeah and then and I wanted
the monsters not so much the Spock I did
like the Spock and the Kirk
and never pulled the trigger on him I
always chose something else at the time
when your mom said pick some
but I and the thing is is how to ruined
the collector's value of being a kid out
of course I'd open it up and played with
it yeah you wanted to buy that [ __ ] and
keep it [ __ ] in the package
now later when the movies came out I
think they did do a couple Limited
uh Toy lines at rakana after modeled
after the start of the Star Wars where
they were smaller ones but they never
really followed through the the Econo I
think they kind of missed it because
when
especially by the time Wrath of Khan
came out if there was like a good Star
Wars type toy line I would have asked
for it
but it would have had to have a big ship
it would have had to have you know what
I mean if I can the crew members
and the problem the problem with Star
Trek is that there weren't any alien bad
guys per sale per se other than the the
Klingons but they didn't really each
movie kind of wasn't really focusing on
that you had to have a lot of really
cool Klingon [ __ ] and I remember that it
didn't really have it
was mostly focused on the Enterprise
you got to have bad guys to sell that
[ __ ] yeah well and the thing about the
original show too is that they kind of
had a different bad guy like every
episode right so you can see how I mean
nowadays they'd be like woo cha-ching
that's like we can make like a million
different like Star Wars did with the
extended Universe like making an action
figure for every single thing that had
appeared for more than five seconds in
the franchise yeah Star Trek pre-dates
the industry knowledge of how to how to
make well it was that Netflix show the
toys that made us they did a whole
episode on Star Trek yeah and it's funny
because they didn't really expect
um it to kind of like catch on the way
it did and it didn't catch on at the
time it was kind of like a little bit
later but they really had to scramble to
like make toys and they said it got so
bad that they were like just taking
random ass like generic toys like kind
of like a ray gun or something that
wasn't even in the show and just like
slapping it in a Star Trek box or like
putting a sticker on it that said Star
Trek what was that one that was like
real famous like that helmet it was like
a helmet like a siren on the flashy
light and it said if they just put a
sticker out of this and starch yeah I
remember that [ __ ] I would never buy
that yeah it wasn't even on the show it
was just like some random toy they had
like the only Star Trek toy I ever
remember buying was a [ __ ] fake
phaser I mean Remember by that and I
think it shot a [ __ ] disc out the
front of it like a little propeller I
think I had something oh yeah I think we
had one of those yeah and they were
cheap and you could buy them but I I had
one of those uh John says that
supposedly Planet of the Apes sold a lot
of merch it was pre-star with yes I
remember those I remember I remember
those dogs and they were cool little
dolls yeah they were they were about the
size of a Star Trek doll
but they were kind of out of my age
group that was kind of before my time
uh I I remember being like in the 70s
probably about six seven eight and I
think that might have Conan sided with
the with the uh the TV series Planet of
the Apes the thing is it was a little
too adult for me I was
I remember at that time I wasn't buying
those I was buying something called
micronauts oh I remember those my
brother had some of those micronauts I
was buying those and they were actually
a Japanese repurposed uh [ __ ] yeah
product which I like those and I was
totally into gona guy
uh Japanese stuff that I was seeing on
channel 22 in California which I did was
get a robo it was big into that and
because I was living in California at
that time
we had some Japanese import shops so I
was buying get a robo and [ __ ] great
mazinger and mazinga all right so great
missinger and just regular mazinger
they got rebooted later on Mattel picked
some of those up and rebooted him as the
Shogun Warriors I bought those too I
still got some
and I got a bunch of other collectible
stuff so I was more into that Japanese
looking stuff at the time the Planet of
the Apes stuff was around but had I
known any better but you're a kid you
know and you're your mom is saying pick
something out you know you're gonna have
you can only have one
so you gotta [ __ ] you know there's
gonna be a lot of losers when you can
only have one yeah you got to do the
winnowing problem yeah you know what I
mean and and a Planet of the Apes looked
cool I remembered it as a kid but it
always lost out over things like
micronauts and Japanese toys
all those Japanese toys eventually
the American the American Executives the
American toy markets eventually started
getting into the Japanese concept and
that ended up being Transformers
Transformers and Voltron yeah you know
they finally jumped on they got him like
way on that well because I mean what's
more badass than like big huge
transforming robots right I can't
believe it took like the US that long to
like catch on to that wave the Go nagai
stuff did come to the United States I
think it was called State
renamed some of the [ __ ] like star uh
Star Warrior a star of this and that
some [ __ ] they would take an entire
series and mash it down into a two-hour
movie
and it and it and what you ended up with
was nothing like the original
uh because
you couldn't show the original in the
United States
the series were too long
they were too adult
there were scenes of like demonic
possessions and people exploding from
within uh scenes of bad guys machine
gunning people
um
the female
Heroes
their uniforms all had nipples on them
which they had a lot of they had a big
problem with that where there were
nipples on the uniform but the was just
from a practical standpoint it's like
why why would you have this
they were because they're originally
written for teenagers well I know that
but I'm just saying I just said from a
practical standpoint I know why they put
them yeah I'm just saying from a
practical standpoint in real life he
would never have well the men had them
too because they were they were all
modeled after
um like Marvel Superheroes so they were
in kind of like superhero outfits
later on that ended up being Power
Rangers and real at Live Action Power
Rangers but in the originals they were
just these colorful outfits with [ __ ]
helmets and [ __ ] capes and
and so they and the girls were all sex
symbols basically they were [ __ ]
well one of them from great mazinger or
it was June Kono who was her dad was a
black GI stationed in Japan with a
Japanese mother and she was being picked
off for being a biracial uh but she
ended up being like a super uh robot
pilot and like uh a super heroine and
she was I think she was
um
she piloted a Mecca I think it was
called Venus a I think what it was and
she was just this sexy robot it was a
sexy female robot and she was sexy in it
with curves and [ __ ] because the
Japanese characters were not drawn with
curves really they were drawn to
Japanese beauty standards of the time
which were Twiggy you know Twiggy chicks
and June was [ __ ] voluptuous it was
just
gona guy was ahead of his time he he was
kind of like the Japanese version of
Stan Lee
and he was trying to bring
um kind of an international Flair to it
and try to broaden the horizons of the
Japanese audience because he had been
outside of Japan and the Japanese are
very you know I got a lot of respect for
their culture but they're very
conformist you you have to be one way
there you can't be any other way and
goat didn't like that he was like no you
could there's a lot of other ways to be
you know so
that's all in these comics
and the comics ended up being
made into movie into television series
some of the [ __ ] had to be cut from the
comics
some of the good guys were also things
like ex-criminals and drug addicts
and they're piloting these things
now not drug acts in terms of like
heroin addicts or anything they were
guys that were like addicted to
amphetamines and [ __ ] like that
um
and the amphetamines made the guys real
fast you know and he's piloted in a dam
robot that is [ __ ] super fast that's
its main strength and you would have to
be on this really high-tech amphetamine
to actually pull it off because you're
doing things that are faster than humans
normal human synopsis and [ __ ] so that
that's an alien concept that you could
never show in the United States
thank you Jeffy
uh sorry off topic uh about your soul
survivor stream eerily one of my friends
knew Kurt Johnson the doctor through
theater circles yeah he died of AIDS in
1986. he sucks his work and life was
brief my friend was glad to see your
video I'm glad to see that movie too
because yeah
you actually say that he died of AIDS
but he was young he was only like 32 34
or something like that like when he he
only died like a couple years after that
so who saw the video
a friend of a friend of Jeffy artzia
that was in the movie or no that knew
him that knew that guy that was in the
movie that played the doctor you know
yeah he played that character yeah it
was a decent movie I like that movie a
lot and like I said I'm just I'm
surprised that I had never heard it
heard of it or seen it so I kind of feel
like hopefully our video like kind of
helps get it out there a little bit
um
Danny Rowling said warlock one and two
would make good Halloween movie reviews
just saying maybe we'll do it that way
I've been wanting to do warlock for a
while I think I saw warlock too a while
back but I don't really remember much
about it I think they might both be on
2B next Dimension media said I had a
Planet of the Apes lunchbox that I was
very proud of I think my brother had
that actually either he had it or I had
it we always thought it was a big deal
back in the 70s and 80s like before when
you were doing your back to school
shopping that was like your best thing
to picking out The Lunchbox and you had
to like be really careful because they
had like a lot of different ones and it
was always just kind of like which one
do I want
grandma said anyone see the incinerated
Owen and Brew toys if those are real it
would have been hilarious no I really
really
would made those because that is super
super funny he also said that is so
funny he also said the good guy is
awesome I'm surprised anybody knows who
the [ __ ] gonna guy is but that's what
people do yeah lots of people do
um granther said Tom Cruise was in the
news today he'll be rocketing up to the
International Space Station to film his
next movie why are we not surprised
I mean
you know it's Tom Cruise he's got to do
that kind of [ __ ] he's got to do that
kind of [ __ ] John Gore said the Axis
powers were notorious putting their
pilots on meth yeah I kind of feel like
a lot of pilot back then well like I
said and they didn't even make a secret
about it even just to access we were
doing it yeah we were doing it too we'd
probably still do it well and like I
said they were open about it too because
I saw there was a movie on and I saw it
on Mystery Science Theater called the
starfighters and it was about the Air
Force and they were absolutely open
about
about being on uppers being on like yeah
yeah so one thing I can't I don't
remember what they called it in the
movie but that that's they were I know
they were doing it in the uh in the 80s
like they were pretty messed out to do
the Dem
um bombing on
um uh what was his name
um
he was the guy that ended up getting
[ __ ] killed by getting stabbed up in
the ass
what yeah Gaddafi Gaddafi got [ __ ]
killed by [ __ ] somebody shoved a
knife up his ass couple times killed him
during that Revolution
or the overthrow
um but no when they bombed Gaddafi's
house in the in the uh in the 80s the
pilots had to do a bunch of refueling
and they didn't have permission to go
through certain countries and uh
evidently they were on uh pet pills to
keep them awake yeah because you had to
be it was a long flight there and back
it was kind of a special operations
flight to [ __ ] dropped these bombs on
his house using f-16s they didn't use a
they didn't use the aircraft carriers
for that
my favorite part of that movie The
starfighters was the whole sequence
about the poopy suit
that was the stuff that was the stuff
that well you had to wear the suit well
that you could poop in yeah because you
were flying right because you're flying
over the uh Atlantic and you're a little
plane yeah I think they all have diapers
on it yeah that's what I mean yeah so
it's just thought that was like funny
that they they put there's a very
extended sequence and they call it a
poopy suit in the movie and I think the
movie came out in the late 50s early 60s
something like that and uh and they're
all like jumping in the pool like trying
to test it for leaks and [ __ ] like that
it was just like so of course so of
course like uh Mike in the Bots like had
to come up with like a poopy suit song
which was quite delightful yeah
that's still standard practice well yeah
I mean what else are you gonna do right
but you know you can't jump out the damn
fighter and take a piss that's what I
mean you can't just I'm gonna go I'm
gonna excuse myself
[Laughter]
so yeah so what do you think about it
from a practical standpoint obviously
that's what they're doing but it's just
funny like to think about it I guess
yeah [ __ ] water and [ __ ] drinks
and [ __ ] food in in the cockpit
so you know they're eating in there too
and then bomber Crews I think back in
the old B-52 days though I think they
had a latrine just like in a uh 747 or a
DC-10 you know I don't think they they
didn't need that
but you know Fighters did
Zach said sorry I'm missing the show
tonight me and the man are heading to
the bar tonight we'll have a good time
we're gonna head to the bar too but
later yeah like because here it's only
quarter to seven so we don't actually
have to leave till like 9 30.
so soon as we finish up here I gotta go
get ready real quick and then we'll
then we'll go and have a few of those uh
canned cocktails yeah that's okay
yeah
then go hang out and get some sandwiches
from Circle K on the way home
like we always do we forgot about that
it's like I don't really I don't know
why that became a thing
I don't know I I guess it was just
because where we lived before you know
stopping by McDonald's and getting
breakfast sandwiches on the way home was
always a thing because it the McDonald's
was like right there and it was open but
now we don't have a McDonald's around us
anymore we have we have to pass the
Circle K so we just got in the habit of
like stopping at Circle K on the way
home and picking up sandwiches
I usually get like a sandwich and like a
little bag of chips or some or crackers
yeah yeah that's good somebody knows
it's about to go in a guy and one of the
golden guy mangas
out of getter Robo get her two you know
Raiden the guy that was fast a fast
skinny guy
in in several of the comic books he's
injecting himself with [ __ ]
methamphetamine
and injects himself with it in [ __ ]
combat to get faster and [ __ ] out
maneuver some [ __ ] which that would
never be allowed in a [ __ ]
American television series for kids
rig enough
[Laughter]
I gotta get faster
yeah can you imagine like the [ __ ]
apocalyptic I mean that people would
still freak out nowadays but can you
imagine like showing that in the 80s oh
my God they would like [ __ ] they
would have had a [ __ ] they could show
[ __ ] and they mine in it and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] the cockpit
because they're trying to save the Earth
you know
from you're trying to save the Earth
from [ __ ] demons from hell and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
funny well you know yeah that's I don't
know it's just like really funny I just
feel like the 80s in the United States
was just like so
anti-drug everything like you know doing
drugs one time it's like oh my God you
do you smoke marijuana one time and like
your [ __ ] whole life spirals down the
toilet you know what I mean like you end
up dying like you're [ __ ] junkie yeah
gas station bathroom like getting butt
[ __ ] by a hobo or something yeah and
then the same guys [ __ ] chanting
[ __ ] all these American slogans and
[ __ ] singing all these patriotic
songs don't realize that they're [ __ ]
elite soldiers are [ __ ] doing math
in the cockpit
uh
well like I said
if the forces taking steroids yeah you
know well the weird thing is that people
seem to make a distinction between drugs
that are illegal and drugs that are
legal and I'm like there's really not
any difference the only difference is an
authority figure goes here take it
we can trust you with it I mean there's
not okay thank you you know
it was a results-based regime in those
days
you had a limited lifespan anyway
in those in those in in those roles
if you survived it you were lucky
you were disciplined enough to learn how
to walk away from any of that but no
uh
I
in the time that I was in to make it and
[ __ ]
in the high in the upper echelons of
Special Forces I mean and my uncle told
me he was in Task Force 160 Special
Operations Aviation he says do you do do
you do performance drugs you you take
these steroids and they're like no
because we have to take those I said
really all right he's like oh no never
mind I didn't believe him no way ah
don't worry about it no [ __ ] those
dudes were all on steroids in the
[ __ ] 90s
and then that same uncle that I'm
telling you about he's older than me
he's jacked to the [ __ ] gills
and he's a private pilot and Private
health Chopper pilot and bodyguard for
some Sultan down in Dubai
he's like
65 and he's just [ __ ] just stacked
okay
Zach says uh I also just finished my
first week at the new job only thing I'm
worried about is it's very
detail-oriented and I'm pretty
scatterbrained so getting a little
nervous there you'll do [ __ ] you'll do
fine you'll be fine
um just take everything very slowly I
know how that is too but
just chill out and make sure like you
got all your teas crossed and your eyes
down it'll be fine Anthony banduca said
I'm more scared to drink a coffee than a
vodka in seven
why are you so why are you scared of
coffee though coffee is delicious and
vodka is delicious too Anthony Johnson
says negroes with machetes in the house
algorithms brought me here word to your
mother
all right oh and look sex spots came and
then sex box sex spots came in your sexy
you brought the sex spots with you
here they come in train yeah okay sex
spots get rid of the sex box people
where's my bouncers where's my bouncers
all right I gotta go pee okay
crafter says of course Gaddafi's death
was filmed and posted on a net yeah yeah
he tried to talk his way out of it that
dude still killed him
and killed unjustly
uh Gaddafi was uh an ally of ours who
[ __ ] did everything we asked him to
do and [ __ ] we betrayed the dude he
gave up his nuclear Arsenal and all
kinds of stuff but when he started
talking about well we need to make a new
Middle Eastern and North African Banks
so we can we can actually do uh
financially develop this this region
they went after him they're not going to
allow you to [ __ ] do anything outside
or back in those days we'll still like
that soon as you start taking down
um U.S hegemony and far start
threatening the [ __ ] U.S petrol
dollar they kill you it doesn't matter
if you're good or bad
and which is one of the reasons why the
U.S Empire [ __ ] corrupt as [ __ ] all
right and eventually these [ __ ]
it's not the people
it's not even the form of government
it's the criminal cartels that have
taken over this government eventually
they're going to pay for what they did
they're abusing too many people
okay let's move on
uh are this Xbox going I don't know
probably
yeah they look like that yeah
they look like they're gone
yeah yeah Zach's in there [ __ ]
bouncing him good job good job
and [ __ ] Anthony comes back and
that's how he rolls all right yeah and
he's giving me the Black Fist go ahead
bro
go ahead machete and all you know you
can't give them sharp objects to them to
those Negroes they're gonna use that
[ __ ] Cold Steel you know guns don't work
on y'all it's got to be something that's
[ __ ] scary and sharp you know that's
why they need to take these guns away
these cops give them all damn hatchets
and then crime will just drop it'll just
vanish okay
Zach says they actually do or his new
job they actually do a bit of a
Scientology thing where if you get under
96 score for how much stuff you scan in
an hour you have to put in steps to stop
that from happening uh oh no that's I I
get it I get it but yeah that's
the Scientology thing well the
Scientology thing wasn't just that it
wasn't just about quality control it was
essentially about
um infinite growth you had to like do
better than last week always like up to
it but I'm like look people have limits
I don't know if you guys know that or
not I know scientologists don't because
they're clearly like Superior to all the
rest of us but yeah so that was that
whole thing
that was that whole thing I think it's
probably time for another drink right
now okay hopefully this thing's making
ice
yeah this would be probably the last one
yeah because right now yeah running out
of orange juice
well yeah I don't want to have another
one anyway because I mean I might not
drink when I go out like or I might just
have like one or two but
I don't want to get too [ __ ] up
because like I said I gotta get ready to
go out and sometimes if I get a little
bit inebriated then I'm like oh I gotta
get ready to go out and I just like you
know I try to do makeup and I'm just
like [ __ ] it whatever and I'm just like
drawing eyebrows on all over the place
and it's just like it doesn't work out
so good you know what I mean so that
kind of happened last Friday I just I
think the makeup looked okay but I was
kind of like rushing to get ready and I
was just kind of like I'm just like it
just I don't know I thought it looked
bad and I couldn't I didn't have time to
fix it I didn't have time to do my nails
they were all [ __ ] up looking and
they're still [ __ ] up looking but
whatever I'll just leave them I'll just
leave them I don't care I don't care but
um
the drunker I get the less I care
but uh yeah so today oh today I was like
I finally figured out I'm not gonna tell
you guys but um I kind of finally
figured out what I'm gonna do for
Halloween because
[Music]
wanted to do something cool for
Halloween you know
so I got all this I haven't bought all
of it yet I bought some of it but
we'll see how it looks when it all gets
here
okay thank you the uh
ice cubes are starting to look a little
more normal
okay
all right
um
little I asked an original member of the
Church of Satan if soldiers took drugs
in Vietnam he was a soldier and started
insulting me not very satanic more
[ __ ] yeah I mean
I kind of thought that was a given I
don't really know
why anybody why anyone would get
offended by that question but
who knows who knows
Zach says so far I've been scanning old
film slides into digital it makes me
want to start film photography so bad
but Christ is it expensive as [ __ ] it is
yeah
[ __ ] I took a photography class in
college like a while back and even that
was [ __ ] expensive I had a grant but
still
I had to like cheap out on pretty much
everything because
I had a grant but because you know I was
[ __ ] poor but it uh barely barely
barely covered tuition and books and
then I had maybe a couple hundred
dollars left over and I took like
graphic design photography and
everything like that and back then you
had to get uh
uh all of the kind of like because there
was computers it wasn't that long ago it
was the 90s but you still had to do all
this stuff like analog so you had to buy
like big huge sets of prismacolor
markers and pencils and all kind of
different like special paper and you
know mounting [ __ ] like you know what I
mean like mounting board and spray Mount
and all that other kind of crap
photography [ __ ] you had to buy all that
stuff so I don't even remember like how
much all of those supplies cost me but a
lot of it came out of my own pocket
obviously because
you know
and let's see Zach said there's actually
a film emulation program for digital
video you can get called dehancer that
looks real cool to use but even that is
400 yeah I mean
that's the thing it's like shit's a lot
cheaper nowadays than it used to be but
it's still a little bit cost prohibitive
for somebody that just wants to do it
for a hobby like if that's kind of your
big main thing and that's what you're
gonna do then I can see spending that
much money on it but holy [ __ ] four
hundred dollars
Danny Rowling said Blair Witch 2 Book of
Shadows would be a good Halloween review
I was
they just saw it I was scrolling through
one of our
services to be Amazon
HBO Max I don't know which one it was
because we have a bunch but maybe it was
shutter
but it was on there so I was thinking
I'm kind of like Curious to watch it
again because I remember back in back in
the day like not too long after it came
out I had it on DVD and I liked it and
then like later on I was like surprised
at how reviled it was I guess because I
was like I remember it being okay
um you know it's nothing like the first
one but that's good I mean that's you
wouldn't want to like rehash the first
[ __ ] so I don't know I'm kind of like
Curious to watch it again because you
know and I said that to Tom and he's
like well I didn't like the first one I
said but yeah but it's nothing like the
first one that's the thing it's not
found footage you know what I mean it's
kind of like meta found it's not found
footage but it's kind of like meta
playing with the idea of found footage
so now did um I knew the dart the new
Dario Argento movie dark glasses
I heard that it was coming to shutter
but I'm gonna mess with that ice maker
again it's glitchy I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] it out there and clean it figure
out what the hell's going on working but
I just had to pull it on hung up
and it hung up on me yeah
but anyway this is our last one anyway
does anybody know if uh uh dark glasses
is on shutter yet
because I do I want to do a review of
that
now tomorrow I think some people brought
up
earlier than new Hellraiser which is on
Hulu I did watch that and I did a review
of that I know like a couple of people
said they didn't really like it but I
actually really liked it it was like way
better than I was expecting I didn't
think it was like brilliant but I
thought it was like actually pretty good
and I really did like the new cenobite
designs so I just I don't know I thought
it was a good story and like I said I
say this in the video tomorrow but
really I only like the first and the
second Hellraiser movies uh the rest of
them I didn't even realize that there
were as many as there were like as many
shitty sequels the rest of them I didn't
even bother watching them but this one
was actually like pretty decent like
definitely worth watching but I don't
know if if dark glasses is on shutter
then I will do a review of that in a
little while
because I have some faces but I remember
like and Hellraiser when it came out and
watched the first one I think it may be
the second one too
but then I went back and saw him later
in before him so they're dated
something about the storytelling you
might like this new one it's not the
same story as the original Hellraiser
it's got Santa bites in it it's got like
the same theme like it has the same it's
in the same universe but it's not that
story it's not it's not an adaptation of
the novella
Anthony says uh do you do reviews yes we
do uh we we do a bunch and I do a bunch
on my own I mostly do movies but I do
books too
um a girl walks home a walks home alone
at night I think I've done that one
but go back and look I'm pretty sure I
did that but it was probably like
several months ago
I'm pretty sure
John Gore said I liked Romero's Season
of the Witch I didn't love it I didn't
love it I it was good but I don't know
there was something about it that like
rubbed me the wrong way I don't I don't
know what it was I'd probably have to
watch it again maybe I was in a bad mood
like when I watched it I liked some of
his earlier [ __ ] like I love Martin for
Christ's sake that's a great [ __ ]
movie we did a review of that one a
really long time ago
but have we we haven't done you know
what Romero movie we haven't done the
crazies
I don't think I've seen them from the
70s I don't think I've seen it it's kind
of like well it's like an infection
yeah like yeah maybe I have seen it but
I had to refresh myself and I think they
remade it in 2010
and I think I saw the Remake and it was
all right but
uh Zach says
I'm actually super hyped for The Last of
Us HBO series next year here's hoping
it's first actually good video game
adaptation we'll see I mean everybody
loves
that video game
so which video game The Last of Us I
haven't played it yeah that's like a big
that's that's a big one
uh Straw Dogs 78 said Bruiser is a great
Romero movie from the early 2000s really
I don't think I ever even heard of that
I don't even think I ever heard of that
uh check out House of the devil I think
I did a review of that too
now that I'm thinking about it the Thai
West one right
I'm pretty sure I did a review if I
didn't then I will eventually
there's a I have a I have a list you
don't even know I've done a [ __ ] ton
like I said we did a bunch together
and then a couple years ago I started
doing because I was I was like look I
have this massive massive list and then
there are some movies that he didn't
really give a [ __ ] about seeing but I
wanted to say so I was like well I'll
just you know do my own reviews of them
and so I started doing that a couple
years ago so
but they're still like a [ __ ] Tom that I
want to do there's like a million
I don't know old ones new ones and they
keep putting out new ones too
I try to do what I try to do this isn't
always what I do I put up two movie
reviews a week just me
I try to do like a newer movie on
Thursday
and an older movie on Saturday but
sometimes that doesn't sometimes I'll do
new movies like on both days just
because there's a bunch that came out or
that I wanted to see like that's what I
did this week I did speak no evil which
was from 2022 because a couple people
asked me about it because it's on
shutter and then people are like oh you
should watch the new Hellraiser that's
on Hulu and I was like okay well I'll do
that so I did two new movies Brian hack
sent me the long version of evil speak I
got the link
I'll share it with you it's like a half
hour longer
oh that wasn't the movie I was talking
about what'd you say no speaking of no
evil okay that's a new movie I got
messed up yeah that was yesterday he
sent me evil speak the uh kind of like a
director's cut yeah okay yeah we've
never seen it yeah we did a review of
that but yeah we could watch the longer
version yeah
Danny Rowling said Dolores Claiborne I
can't wait until you review that yeah we
need to do that one too
because that's one of the better Stephen
King adaptations that we haven't done
is Dolores Claiborne
and let's see uh Hugo said I like the
second Hellraiser because it has a lot
of practical effects but the first is a
good one yeah the first one's the best
one but the second one is actually like
better than it had any right to be I
think the third one
I'm pretty sure I saw it but I don't
really remember anything about it
ever see Fade to Black from 1981 it's
got a young Mickey Rourke I did I
watched that
um probably last year I was actually
gonna do a review of it but then
I watched it and then I was like ah like
I didn't love it so I said well maybe
I'll come back to it and like do a
review of it later but I don't think I
ever did but I did kind of like watch it
so we'll see
uh let's see what else
The Misfits have a cameo and Bruiser
featuring their song Bruiser well now I
have to see that [ __ ] now I have to see
it
I don't think I ever even like heard of
that
so I'm going to write that down I'm
gonna write that down
yeah Ben said Hellraiser 3 was the silly
one where the cenobites wanted around
massacring people in some City
maybe I didn't see that one then
I was looking the other day because I
didn't even realize that they had made
so many like they made a [ __ ]
Hellraiser move like the ninth one or
whatever like in 2018 I'm like holy [ __ ]
really
but I mean Doug Bradley wasn't in it he
was in most of them which actually
surprised me I thought he would have
noped out earlier but
he's probably like eh whatever paycheck
then he can go to Lahore conventions
because he's Pinhead you know but
I have to say like the stills from the
last one and the last like the last two
sequels which I what the [ __ ] were they
called
uh they always have like one word names
it was like Hellraiser blah like
Revelation or whatever though they're
all like biblical
but they had I don't know who the guy
was that they had playing him in the
2018 one or the 2011 one but
um let's just say that if he turned up
his Pinhead I don't think I would be all
that scared he didn't really look all
that intimidating to be honest if Doug
Bradley showed up like looking like
Pinhead I'd probably [ __ ] myself but if
this guy turned up I'd be like ready
what are you doing man it really did
seem like they really really cheaped out
well and I and I talked about this on
the on my Hellraiser video that's going
up tomorrow too is that
I think that a lot of the Hellraiser
sequels were actually made just to hold
on to the rights to the property you
know what I'm saying like they didn't
really give a [ __ ] about they were just
like whatever just put out a Hellraiser
movie and slap help the name Hellraiser
on it so we can like keep the right
that's basically it
uh Doug Bradley is in wrong turn five
which is decent wait there's a wrong
turn
I saw the first one
and I knew that there was a second one I
didn't I I wasn't aware that there were
five it's it's amazing to me
how some horror franchises that you
would think
like the first movie even if like the
first movie was fine
you would think that like why would
anybody want to make more of those
but somebody must be watching them and
buying them otherwise they wouldn't keep
doing it which serious Doma well they're
talking about Wrong Turn well like I
said the first one was good but it's
like that's another one of those movies
you know what I mean like like Children
of the Corn like I really like the first
Children of the Corn it's like cheesy as
[ __ ] I get that
but I really like the first Children of
the Corn but who would have guessed that
that would become like a whole [ __ ]
franchise how many of those how many
children of the core movies are there
like six seven eight some [ __ ] like that
I'm like that's crazy
and weren't we talking about that the
other day too with like trancers and
yeah I think there was a bunch of those
there's a bunch of Puppet Master movies
and like I said I'm not [ __ ] on
you know the first ones because usually
the first ones are good but sometimes it
just seems like oh that was good but it
wasn't anything like special but then
for some reason it spawns like 9 10
movies which is [ __ ] crazy okay let
me plug if you guys could man hit hit
the uh the like button and uh like share
subscribe thank you that's all I want to
say and of course super chats are active
Anthony said assuming you have seen
Carnival of Souls yes I've seen it many
many times actually we just reviewed
that not too long ago I I think it was
not too long ago and a movie that we
just talked about a few days ago which
is called Soul Survivor from the 80s
like 84 was actually strongly influenced
by Carnival of Souls if you like
Carnival of Souls you'll probably like
that one as well
um I think Jenny and Tom would love Star
Trek DS9 yeah you've seen that you've
seen that right I've seen episodes like
here and there he's talking about
Jeffrey Combs I've seen it where yeah he
did the gem hodar [ __ ] um clone
leader of all the [ __ ] Jim Hadar yeah
he and he did some other stuff too
but uh yeah I liked it I liked those
episodes real good
although I'm going to say when it comes
to Star Trek Jeffrey Combs best [ __ ]
work is on Enterprise Star Trek
Enterprise where he plays [ __ ]
General Tran or it's a general Tran or
Commander Tran I don't remember
um his shrag character is [ __ ] great
man he's kind of like
the [ __ ] George Patton a [ __ ]
alien world really good I love Jennifer
Combs yeah
one of these days if you're watching
Jeffrey Combs we want you to be on the
show yeah he plays an endorian come be
on the show and drink with us yeah and
hang out and we'll talk about horror
movies yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
Tom's Place in andorian [ __ ] ship
captain with the [ __ ] the blue guys
with the antennas and the white hair
and all kinds of [ __ ] happens to that
[ __ ] character over time he's trying
to kind of kind of becomes [ __ ] cat
marcher's friend
but uh they were little the andorians
[ __ ] the males are little they're
little guys you know five four five five
and all the females are taller
and uh they caught embossed the females
around and [ __ ] but then it turns out
the females run the male the males and
his little [ __ ] sub-commander the
tenant
turns out [ __ ]
Archer finds out that
he got her pregnant he's got to marry
her now because she raped him [ __ ]
some weird [ __ ] you know what I mean
[ __ ] I liked it and he says well I
couldn't say no because she did she
would have killed me you know because
they were kind of like praying mantises
which that was [ __ ] that was kind of
a cool angle and then [ __ ] um
shran eventually loses the command of
his ship for some [ __ ] because he was
working the [ __ ] and Dorian
government was all [ __ ]
criminal and corrupt and he becomes a
[ __ ]
basically a thief professional Thief
[ __ ] stealing drool jewels and [ __ ]
becomes a pirate he's pretty good man
for good good series
Ben says yeah they just added the Santa
bites into random horror scripture the
last five Hellraisers that's uh yeah
that was my understanding and I think I
mentioned that like on my Hellraiser
review which is going up tomorrow or you
know you've probably already seen it if
you're a patron because I put it up
early
but it's going public tomorrow but yeah
that's kind of what they did like I said
they were trying to hang on to the
rights to the IP like the Hellraiser IP
so what they would do is they would just
like uh they're like hey you have a
random horror script yeah it doesn't
have anything to do with Hellraiser
that's okay
um we're just gonna write Pinhead into
it and then call it Hellraiser or blah
blah you know what I mean so yeah they
did that so they clearly didn't really
get much of a crap about the [ __ ]
franchise
um Ben says also says Puppet Master
movies are great if you haven't followed
them the puppets are now the heroes I
saw I saw one on riff tracks the other
day I think it was what was it retro
Puppet Master the more they went back in
time I kind of have to go back and watch
the whole thing though because I think
like I was like really really tired and
I I usually like to if it's kind of the
end of the night and I'm getting sleepy
like usually I'll put like a rip tracks
on
um but I don't it's very very rare for
me to like be able to stay awake for the
whole like hour and a half so I think I
fell asleep because when I woke up I was
like wait I think the next movie had
come on so you know what I mean but it
looked funny yeah Ben said didn't Kirk
have an endorian girlfriend no there's a
scene in the original in the original uh
series
although I think it might have been an
illusion or something where somebody
appears to to Kirk or Kirk is that some
kind of dance and there's a um
uh what did you call them
an Orion female an Orion there's no okay
there's two I think there might have
been two times where he deals with an
Orion females there was the green girls
one where he goes to a dam it's insane
asylum and a sexy Orion
patient there tries to seduce him
she ends up getting blown up by her
boyfriend her human boyfriend is a
[ __ ] psycho
uh and the other one where he's at some
kind of he's having an hallucination and
he's kind of in this situation where he
sees some girl that he knows in the form
of an Orion
and they're green and they were Orion
slave girls in the series
but then you find out later on and you
find out an Enterprise
that the Orion slave girls the Orion
females actually gave off all these damn
powerful pheromones
where
Orion males and and human males couldn't
resist them
it turned out that they weren't slaves
they had actually enslaved all the men
[ __ ] the men served them men traded
them and sold them off but they only did
it when they when when the female wanted
that to happen
that's some wild [ __ ]
um
so it looks like like like like like
misogyny but no they were actually just
obeying what the females wanted they
lived a [ __ ] privileged class
privileged his life and they [ __ ]
were dictating what was going to happen
to him next and it was because of their
pheromones they could they could control
males
but they hid the fact though so that was
that I would too if I yeah yeah [ __ ]
although one of the one of the Orion
males [ __ ] they've tried to save the
female and he was like you don't
understand our culture so they they were
like I remember that episode yeah it's
like you don't understand our culture
wait was that the one with uh Lou
Ferrigno in it yeah yeah that was from
Star Trek Continues yeah that's right
but that but that also basically kind of
happens in Star Trek Enterprise yeah
that's what I thought um you showed me
Enterprise right I get confused because
I don't think we saw all of it though
season or two
yeah we watched I mean
for me like I said I'm not I don't think
I'd call myself a Trekkie but I really
do like the Original Series yeah the
andorians were not green no they were
blue they had antennas white hair
and the the girls were tall and thin
and they seem to be kind of like
subordinate
to the little males but they were more
like
praying mantises if they made a move on
you you had to [ __ ] submit or they
would kill you
yeah like I'm praying mantis yeah
so so sharan basically got raped
he couldn't say no or she would have
killed him yeah and she chose him and he
couldn't say no
so that's pretty cool [ __ ] it's just
different ways of talking about because
that's the way it is in the animal
kingdom
and if they were aliens there would be a
bunch of unexp unexpected mating
[ __ ] procedures going on well yeah I
liked it a lot of sci-fi kind of like
explores that kind of yeah that kind of
[ __ ] yeah you know what I mean it's
funny because when we were at mannequins
last week and our friend Laura was there
and Laura who is she's significantly
younger than us yeah which one you know
oh uh that Laura because we know several
Laura's okay yeah now she's not saying
she's about 31 32. that's what I mean so
significantly yeah
um but I mean she might be in her
mid-30s I'm not I'm not entirely sure
you can't tell by looking at her no you
can't oh it looks like she she looks
just like she did when she was a kid
when I met her yeah she hasn't changed
yeah but she
um just discovered
the original Star Trek series yeah and
so we got into like a long discussion
about it and she has like all these
pictures of gifts of Spock in her phone
now because she's like oh I get it now
like this whole and she was just telling
me like how beautiful like Spock was and
everything and I'm like see and she she
thought she was a weirdo for like
thinking that and I was just like you
don't understand
I was like you haven't been to our house
been to our house in a while but I was
like I haven't eaten I have a [ __ ]
cardboard cut out yeah a Spock right
there yeah Sophie gave that to us I yeah
that's a present but that was a birthday
present from so it's mirror Spock though
that's mirror that's mirror from the
other universe but I mean regular Spock
is hot too yeah honestly you know would
be cool just you know if anybody wanted
to give me a present for Christmas or
something would be like another
cardboard cutout like that but like
regular spots regular spot so I could
put them like next to each other so it'd
be like that'd be a really cool action
from both the universe you could have
them for both universes because I mean I
like that I like that spot because of
the beard and everything but I like
regular Spock mostly because
I mean there wasn't a big difference
between the two spocks that's what I
mean and miracles was the universe that
they were in Mary Universe Bach was only
in like one or two episodes right uh
he's in one episode of the original
series and he's in uh Star Trek Star
Trek Continues what happens and I really
recommend Star Trek Continues which is a
fan made with Vic mignona and a lot of a
lot of like descendants of the original
cast members and written by people for
the did the original series it's it's
it's some of the best Star Trek of all
times it's the final series It's the
final
It's the final season to the original
series
and they revisit the mirror episode to
find out what happened to mirrors mirror
Spock and then what happened to mirror
Kirk he's in it too
after the Enterprise sent sends him back
to his own Universe releases it from
prison and sent him back to his own
Universe he does some [ __ ] in the other
Universe too they fight over the damn
Enterprise and a revolution starts off
it's it's good a real good episode it's
called Uh fairest of them all starts
yeah it continues fairest of them all
you can see it for free on YouTube yeah
it's like a continuation of yeah yeah I
mean the purple series the production
value in this are really really high but
obviously because it's fan-made like
they can't make any money off of it and
they just made it because they were into
it yeah and they just released it for
free so you can watch it for free it's
an HD it's
as good or better than you than the
original series better it's like the Top
Notch from from the original series in
terms of [ __ ] it's even got better
special effects and the acting's [ __ ]
excellent
it's got different people playing the
roles but they're real good well
obviously because yeah Todd haberkorn
plays Spock he's real good Vic mignona
plays Kirk and they're real good real
good he does Kirk well without doing a
Shatner impersonation
he does he's a real good Kirk
Zach said last weekend I was shooting
something for a friend and he had a Will
Smith cut out in his office that jump
scared me so bad when I went to use the
bathroom yeah can you imagine like what
the [ __ ] is Will Smith doing here John
Gore said I like the episode where Spock
where Spock uh sniffed some flower and
becomes a hippie I remember that one
yeah what was that that was when they
were on that damn that played it where
they had those [ __ ] plants that had
taken over I'm not going back Jim that
was uh that was a drug that was a drug
[ __ ]
um uh statement about drugs that yeah
drugs are good but they can make you not
give a [ __ ] that's and you need which is
which is one of the reasons why they're
good yeah but that [ __ ] but in certain
situations yeah they were talking about
drug addiction though right you know I
liked that because I mean as much as I
love Spock and his all like I don't know
I have this weird thing
where I really like these fictional
characters that are like Spock that are
just kind of like very very logical and
like that but then I like them like that
most of the time but then every now and
then it's cool like if they're in that
kind of episode where he acts like
totally different I don't know why I
like that it's the same reason that I
like remember how I told you guys how I
had like a crush on Lurch from that
original Ass Family series and the one
why why are you laugh at me okay yeah
it's a like you know what I mean so I
was into that because he's all like yeah
and so I I was into that but I also
really liked that they had an episode
where him and Wednesday like she was
taking like ballet classes and he was
like try like helping her out with
ballet classes and he had like a tutu
off I didn't see it and it's like I just
I was like oh my God that's so awesome I
don't know why like I don't want him to
be like that all the time necessarily
but I I just like I don't know I just
like that juxtaposition so I like any
time that Spock that's why I really like
his pond far episode too because it's
like I like Spock the way he is like all
the time but then I like that every now
and then like he's allowed to like bust
out you know what I mean and be like
ponfar we see what happened what
happened was is that originally that
series
was kind of written around Kirk that
Kirk was going to be kind of like a
heroic love interest all right of that
movie kind of like leading man for the
first
series but by the time the second by the
time that first series had had finished
they had all this fan mail from women
about
Spock yeah
so they came up with a with a try and
there was some stuff about bones too
they came up with his Triad
um concept
to where Star Trek is really about three
different guys that's bones Kirk
and Spock
and they were different manifestations
of masculinity all right and that's what
the show became about and that's my
favorite thing about the original Triad
thing [ __ ] happened like the
interaction the interaction between
those three and it doesn't well that's
why I don't like the other ones as much
because it's like that was
um that was really kind of a result of
those three actors and those three
characters like interacting with what
like their chemistry with one another
with with Kirk you had aggression and
brashness all right and and and and and
and I guess leadership charisma
with Spock you had intellectualism and
and like psychological depth and then
with bones it was compassion so that's
and the the series makes a lot more
sense
once that starts the Triad Concept in
the writing started to happen I liked
bones too because he was like not only
empathetic like and compassionate but he
was also like kind of a smartass yeah
and he was very forthright like if he
thought you were full of [ __ ] he would
tell you to your face and of course the
opposite of intellectualism is is is is
compassion really you know because it's
emotional based so it's always bones
taking a piss out of [ __ ] spot they
love each other yes but they're but they
they did but this is all uh uh this is
all a a [ __ ]
um man crush three-way man crush between
these two see that's what I was
responding to I really really like those
three characters like interacting with
one another that was like the most
entertaining thing for me yeah they
weren't the series didn't say that
any one of those personality types was
better than the other ones they were
saying that they all kind of completed
one another that they complimented one
another and it was just different
manifestations of of masculinity is what
they're talking about
and they never what made the original
Trek so good and including Next
Generation
and and to a certain extent
Enterprise it never told you what to
think it showed you different things and
you came up with your own
with your own um
uh a [ __ ] what do you call it you
came up with your own opinion you know
never dictated to you it didn't it was
not preachy it would just show you
things and you came up with your own
um uh [ __ ] opinions over about what
happened it was always open-ended stuff
when it gets pretty cheap people check
out that they don't want to be preached
too yeah
Jeffy Hart points out that vulcan's
actually have very Ardent emotions they
just try they just have training to
suppress them yeah I think that's kind
of what I was like responding to with
that character Ben said there was a
kindergartner who told the police that a
man across the street was constantly
glaring at them out his window the
police went to talk to him and found out
it was a Terminator cardboard Arnie
maybe I should put this block by the
window and like put him out there and
see how long it takes for the neighbors
to complain
um Anthony said oh this is this open up
can of worms what do you think about
Mulholland Drive Mulholland Drive is
easily one of my favorite movies of all
time I love David Lynch he's my favorite
he's my favorite director
um and Mulholland Drive is my favorite
movie of his I think what's up Brian I
talked about you earlier I think I did a
review it was a while back it was like
several years ago but I think I like
went on and on for like 45 48 minutes or
something like that and there was still
like a bunch of [ __ ] I didn't cover but
you know yeah one of these days I'll
probably do a revisit but I love
Mulholland Drive seriously yeah Ben said
that
um Roddenberry was a Libertarian he was
a libertarian
and uh he was also like uh real
practical I mean there was some [ __ ]
that came out of that series he let his
writers write [ __ ] stories all right
and each one of them was supposed to be
social commentary a good one was the one
on racism what was called uh with the
guys that were half white and half black
on two different sides yeah that [ __ ]
was great all right and then and and and
[ __ ] it was these two races of aliens
that just could not [ __ ] stand at
each other and it's called let let this
be your last Battlefield and [ __ ] the
way that ended it's like [ __ ] both y'all
Chase each other around on a destroyed
planet for the rest of your [ __ ] life
that was how that [ __ ] is every time I
see their faces all I think of is those
black and white cookies yeah that was a
good one and then another one that was
real important and these dudes were all
War veterans out of [ __ ] second world
wars they knew about war and it was one
where they go to this damn planet and
they had sanitized War to attack to it
to a point to where it was virtual there
was no actual fighting it was simulated
fighting and if you died in a simulated
attack you walked into a dab
disintegrator yeah and [ __ ] Kirk is
spocker watching this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is this all about they were like well we
have to do it this way if not it'll
destroy the planet and all these Horrors
will come back I'm [ __ ] Spock and
Kirk are tripping and [ __ ] Kirk is
like war is [ __ ] horrible that's why
people don't do it
you know like so their solution was they
destroyed all these main computers and
the the ability to simulate it this is
now you have to fight for [ __ ] real
all right this war has been going on for
centuries and millions and millions of
people have [ __ ] died because you
desensitize it now go at each other and
you know and they go what are we gonna
do now to go talk to peace
okay now that was a good episode that's
the [ __ ] that's that's the truth
behind [ __ ] warfighting it's supposed
to be horrible it's inhuman it's murder
it's exactly what you see in Apocalypse
Now all right it's kind of like
something out of the damn drug cartel
Wars that's really what it is and
anytime you try to sanitize it you just
accelerate it make it horrible so people
don't do it
make people pay make the people who
order it pay
yeah then they won't order it to happen
Jeffy Hart said Kirk and Spock fan
fiction actually started the concept of
character shipping in the current pop
culture circles yep that's right fans
would put copies of these stories and
circulated conventions yeah that's the
thing I kind of feel like I don't know
it's weird I don't really think that
that was the intention when the show
came out but you know
fans gonna fan so that's just what's
gonna happen they didn't have a word for
it back then but yeah yeah uh she redid
her hair that's that's her natural hair
right and no we haven't seen uh Tara on
a prairie yet prayer yet we can't cast
it to our TV so we have to watch it on
our devices we have to watch it
separately uh but we'll see it I mean
unless you want to come in here and sit
behind me and like watch it on my big
computer yeah we can do that too we can
do that we can do that too
um yeah Jeffy Hart said Gene Roddenberry
was also a humanist who believed mankind
will eventually evolve Beyond organized
religion he was also for racial equality
yeah you could kind of tell that you
could kind of tell that was in the show
Brian Smith said uh Hey guys glad I get
to see the show live
uh yeah we're glad you're here
Zach says I don't know why but David
Lynch's movies never appealed to me much
I think Wild at Heart is my favorite but
I still barely understand it Wild at
Heart isn't that weird
um to be honest with you I think that's
one of his more accessible movies I
really like Wild at Heart me and my
friend used to watch it all the time
like in the 90s and used to quote it at
each other but I don't know like all his
movies are good something about his
movies just really kind of resonates
with me I get that everybody doesn't
you know I I get that everybody doesn't
get that same kind of thing but I don't
know like it's it's almost kind of like
he's pulling things out of my psyche
sometimes but yeah Mulholland Drive is
my favorite but really like all of them
are good all of them are good I kind of
feel like I should probably do more I've
done Mulholland Drive we did a racer
head
um we did Lost Highway didn't we We Lost
Highway yeah yeah I'm pretty sure we did
well like the show Brian
I kind of wanted to do
um
at some point I want to do Inland Empire
I have it
and I keep saying that I'm going to do
like all of the Twin Peaks series
because I have like the box set of all
three seasons and one of these days I've
seen the first two seasons I still
haven't watched the third one but I need
to like sit down and watch the whole
thing like in one day and I want to do
like a big like [ __ ]
video of it but eventually I'll do it I
just haven't had time to like sit down
and watch it because I really want to
like sit down and be able to pay
attention to it and I just never have
time to I never have enough chunk of
time to like do that to pay attention to
one thing
and let's see
um what else best line of Wild at Heart
peanut what goes on in your head is got
some private mystery
he does he calls her penis and I was
like that makes me laugh I don't know
why like I always kind of think of like
um
well a lot of the things I think of a
while at heart are uh Crispin Glover
being Jingle Bell like I'm making my
lunch like that was something that we
used to say all the time
and I don't know why but like Laura Dern
like being in the hotel room and then
like her just like throwing up and like
leaving the puddle there like on the
side of the floor like in this hotel and
like Nicholas Cage coming back and like
saying how it smelled in there she's
like oh I barfed like I don't know why
like that's so funny to me but I don't
know I really need to see that [ __ ]
movie again because I [ __ ] love that
but yeah Brian we'll just watch it from
the computer yeah we probably will we
probably will
Ben said I did a binge a couple months
ago watched all the Twin Peak stuff
seasons one two and three and fire walk
with me and the extra material see
that's what I want to do too because I
also I have a box set of like all of the
Twin Peaks and I have fire walk with me
and I was just gonna because that's what
I was planning to do and I've had this
[ __ ] for a really long time and I just
haven't had like a significant enough
chunk of time to do it and like I said I
still want to do Inland Empire too but
that's another one that I'm going to set
aside because that's a long ass movie
and that's another movie Mulholland
Drive is not really like a mystery to me
anymore because I've seen it so many
times and it's like you know I get it
Inland Empire is still
um
I kind of get it but
I'm not sure if I entirely get it you
know what I'm saying like I need to see
it a few more times because I feel like
David Lynch movies you need to watch
them at least three or four times before
you kind of start to
for your understanding starts to Dawn
and Inland Empire is like the David
lynchiest movie that you have ever
[ __ ] seen you know what I'm saying
it's like if you were just kind of like
oh that's so David lynchey it's like
yeah watch Inland Empire you'll see it's
like the lynchiest [ __ ] [ __ ] you've
ever seen but you know plus it's shot on
digital video which I didn't love but
and that bit at the end with if you've
seen it you know what I'm talking about
like that bit at the end with Laura Dern
and her face being all like [ __ ]
distorted and stuff it's like I I don't
know why that it but it really like
unsettles me and it's like even now I've
seen it like two or three times and it's
like it still like freaks me out and I
can't really watch it so I have to kind
of like either skip over it or just kind
of like go in the other room like when
that part is on because it's like time
we have left
uh it's 7 37. that's not what I asked
you how much time we have left
don't be an [ __ ] I don't remember can
you not can you not I don't remember I
don't remember what time 20 minutes 20
minutes okay
because I don't remember what time we
had stopped
you guys said I like David Lynch's
rabbits yeah and that was all in
um Inland Empire too like I don't know
if the whole thing was in there but
there were like pieces of rabbits in
there as well
Straw Dogs 78 said Twin Peaks the return
is pretty much one Mega Movie cut up
into 17 episodes its own thing yeah
that's that's why I'm kind of like
I was just waiting for like the right
moment to watch it you know what I mean
uh let's see
you guys should review Zach says we
should review the original Fargo movie
too yeah that's another one that I
wanted to do because Western no it's not
okay it's like a murder mystery but it's
like a dark comedy it's the Coen
Brothers it's the same guys that did No
Country for Old Men and uh you know all
that you probably I don't know like
would you think it was funny I thought
it was funny I thought it was hilarious
but
but like I said it's a very very dark
comedy
Pookie's beating up that little round
mask the little round striped Mouse
she keeps looking at it and I guess it's
moving
funny she likes to pretend that she's
pretending that she like sits there and
stares at you like with her head to the
side like that sometimes she'll pick it
up with her paw and throw it and then be
like it's always that same one the
orange stripe and then she'll sit there
and look at it and it's not moving
obviously because she's pretending it's
a toy yeah and then she'll be like yeah
she'll like Jump On It
we were watching there's a documentary
on Netflix last night so that was about
what's it called Inside the Mind of a
cat or something like that and we were
watching that last it was only like an
hour long
and um
we were I'm kind of glad that they're
doing a lot more cat studies nowadays
because it does seem like and they kind
of brought this up on the thing on the
documentary but they were saying you
know they've done like [ __ ] tons of
research about dogs and like dogs
interaction with humans and [ __ ] like
that but they haven't really done a lot
of cat stuff
even though like I don't know I still
feel like nowadays people think that
cats are like not as social as dogs or
like not as into their owners or
something like that but it's like that's
absolutely not the case if you've ever I
mean all cats are different obviously
but I don't know if priorities are
different yeah that's what you just
can't like set up the same way you can't
yeah you can't approach them the same
way you approach a dog it's like they
you know they love you and they interact
with you and stuff like that but it's
different you know what I mean it's just
different cats are Chase machines you're
just a little Chase creature
chasing and grabbing yeah
chasing grabbing the cats don't want to
scrutinizing them too closely yeah
pretty much
uh Brian Smith says I laugh when Tom
talks about growing up in Mississippi he
makes it sound like it's another country
but I'm in South Arkansas and it sounds
normal to me yeah well you have to
travel around you go up and you go up to
Massachusetts and stuff they have no
idea they're like what yeah totally
different
it is it is a different country for them
even Michigan it would be totally it was
totally different
I don't know I kind of feel like
most of the places that I've been to
I don't know there's always kind of like
one overriding culture I guess but
there's always like other [ __ ] going on
so it's almost I don't know I never
really get it depends on the era you're
talking about that too a lot of this
stuff I'm talking about is 70s and 80s
in the South it was it was a different
country back then back then
yeah that's true
I mean [ __ ] even where I I mean I grew
up in Florida in Daytona Beach thank you
Gadget 3 sorry it's been a while that's
okay thank you very much love you both
oh we love you too thank you very much
that's very nice of you
but yeah it's like I'm you know growing
up in Daytona Beach which was I'm sure
it's different now I've been back in a
long time
I haven't lived there for a long time
but
it's just it was very very rednecky when
I was growing up and it's probably not
like that now I mean I'm sure it's
probably still pretty rednecky because
it still has like NASCAR and all that
stuff there but like because you know
this area I used to live in this area 10
years ago
it's one of the first places I lived in
when I moved to Florida
and it was far more redneck than it is
now a lot of stuff's been built
new people have moved in a lot of them
from other states
and the Rednecks that were running the
show
are now
in their 670s
and they're kind of Aging out so it's
it's
changed
you know just then it's always like that
yeah I mean you talked about I mean My
Sushi there's a sushi restaurant up the
street that wasn't here
10 years ago well yeah that's what I was
gonna say is that you wouldn't have seen
something like that yeah like 10 years
ago no you know what I mean but and uh
Publix that's new
yeah there's all kinds of all kinds of
stuff is just sprouted up and now it
I'm talking about right here
you go up the road here
10 miles to Mount Dora
no it was always
more developed there
less there's more it's like a little
British Town kind of
yeah Mount Dora has always kind of been
it's small but it's always kind of been
known for I mean I kind of feel like
it's known for like antiquing but it's
known for like being kind of like a
really quaint yeah like cool little
downtown like that was always kind of
like Arty like it had kind of all these
little Arty shops and like little book
shops and little restaurants and all
that kind of stuff it's been like that
for like a really long time kind of
English Colonial looking architecture
yeah like that kind of stuff it's
actually it's actually pretty cool down
there it's very very small but Florida
is older than the United States you know
they were here in the 1500s coming in
and they're just there's all kinds of
people were here
it was part of the Spanish Empire but at
the same time even when it was under the
control of the Spanish Empire the Dutch
were here they were little British towns
here
and then I think it might have been
parts of it might have actually been
under British control for a limited
amount of times but then eventually it
got it all got purchased by the United
States and I think that was in uh 1810
was it there no
1790s Maybe
yeah I don't remember it might have been
1810
you guys can check it out Jeffy art said
if a genie granted me only one wish it
would be to have no cat allergies
I feel so bad for like people that have
cattle I can't even imagine being like
allergic to cats because I love cats
and I couldn't imagine like not having
one around especially now that we have
little Pokey no our little our little
daughter
yeah that's what you call her she's our
daughter
uh Brian Smith said I'm 33 and there
really hasn't been much change around
here we drive 30 minutes just for a
Walmart
how how close is the nearest Walmart to
here
I don't Mark oh we went to that Walmart
yeah it's about six miles yeah Six Mile
eight miles something 16 miles yeah it's
kind of
I had never been to that Walmart like
since we moved heavily used Walmart it's
uh yeah that's a nice way of putting it
it's a heavily used heavily used
it doesn't have a damn tile on the floor
it's just kind of cot smooth concrete
and uh it's pretty beat up it's uh
it's always packed every time I've been
there
and it's all kind of like lower to
Middle income but you can go in there
and you can get certain things down
there for a pretty good deal you know
what I mean like any of those any of the
kind of Hispanic foods you can get them
in big bulk quantities at decent prices
you go in there and get a big old case
of eggs
um
big old things a damn cereal so there's
certain things you go to Walmart for
yeah but then there's certain things I
wouldn't buy from Walmart like uh the
meat
the fresh meat doesn't look that good
well everything's always kind of leaking
packages seem to be yeah you know that
Walmart like I've only been to that one
once but it just it really is kind of
like not really all that it's junky it
is very junky chunky that's it's janky
that Walmart yeah but I mean well the
thing about it and it's far like to be
honest for just like regular [ __ ] it's
like oh I need some shampoo or something
we just go to Dollar General because
that's like right there like you could
walk to Dollar General for Christ's sake
it's like right outside the neighborhood
yeah and then if you need like grocery
like meat or salad or anything like that
you just drive up to Publix and that's
like what a mile mile and a half yeah
maybe Publix is Publix is Publix is
always nice that's that's a real nice
groceries I don't think I've ever been
in a shitty Pub no they're all good they
I mean they they keep their [ __ ] tight
they keep everything clean they keep
everything like really Publix forced
wind Dixie to up its game they did yeah
because I I you know where I grew up
like in Daytona our closest store was a
wind actually our closed captioning not
available
um you can get cheap kind of like
or good quality but low cost kind of
like I'd call them
ethnic foods which is red deck Foods
southern food that's their thing okay
you can get that there
um it's a nicer shopping experience than
it used to be it's got a good
um like Buffet we'll call it buffets
that you call it
like a bar like a yeah you can get
salads in there you can get hot stuff
like macaroni and cheese or whatever
yeah it's it's kind of like a buffet
type thing there because I think a lot
of people go in there like for work like
you can go in there and get like you
know pasta salad and [ __ ] like that like
if you're at work or whatever you can
get cold cuts pasta bars cold cuts to
order of all different kinds of meats uh
[ __ ] cheeses to order
and then you can get um stuff like
seafood there
get a really good deal
there for a time you can get really good
deal on King Crab Legs there and crab
legs are different kinds
although I think the the I think the
prices have gone up
well I kind of feel like for if you were
gonna get king crab legs we always had
to wait until because for whatever
reason Winn-Dixie was the only store
that ever and they were expensive there
too yeah but every now and then if you
got lucky they would do a deal like on
them and they'd be like fairly cheap so
then you'd have to go and like stock up
yeah we went there one time
and then the girl running the bar we
were in there God kind of golfed out and
[ __ ] the girl behind the bar liked us
just look I got all this extra stuff
that has to go and she gave us a bunch
of extra [ __ ] pieces of crab legs
remember that and we ended up with like
another pound of [ __ ] crab meat that
we didn't pay for
she's like this is all gonna be thrown
out but it's good
all right here you guys want it they're
like yeah so we had a [ __ ] big bag
yeah we did a whole crab boil yeah I did
a whole crab got potatoes and corn on
the cob and everything yeah put it all
out
newspaper yeah
pretty good we need to do that again one
of these days
got to go to Winn-Dixie to get that when
when the time is right I don't even I
don't even know if there's a Winn-Dixie
around here is there then another thing
that we guys we got Trader Joe's and
what's the other one
oh we got Aldi's yeah there's an Aldi
not too far from here yeah I think
Trader Joe's and Aldi's is the same
thing right now I thought one of I
thought they were related I don't think
so okay Trader Joe's was I think that's
also mostly European stuff though I
think wouldn't it
oh I don't know or there were two
different Aldi's and there's two
different they're called Aldi but the
colors of the signs are different
um Trader Joe's the Trader Joe's is one
of them and there's two different
versions of Trader Joe's that's what I'm
thinking of also
um
but I don't remember the name of the
other Trader it's Trader Joe's and then
there's another one
well there's the same company
I don't remember okay I mean there's
Whole Foods which is like super exciting
that but that's like all the really like
high-end [ __ ] yeah
I don't think I've ever been to a Whole
Foods
I've been all day before
um
I don't know it's just like I said
there's not really a lot really close to
here yeah we got a Dollar General within
walking distance
but other than that nothing it sounds
like Piggly Wiggly
yeah murder pigly yeah
for what I don't know why but like where
I grew up
um
our closest grocery store was Goodings I
don't think they're I don't think that's
a thing anymore I don't think Goodings
is around anymore and I remember that
place being kind of shitty it was kind
of in
it was in a strip mall
I don't remember what else was in there
I think it was it was the Goodings and
it was like a shitty appliance store and
then there was an Arthur Treacher's when
Arthur Treacher's used to be a sit-down
restaurant do you remember that yeah
vaguely yeah like it was over there and
it was on like kind of like the shitty
Street it wasn't like ghetto ghetto but
it was kind of like ghetto adjacent yeah
but that was like the closest one now
when I got a little bit older
uh then they opened a Win Dixie and a
Food Lion like right next to each other
like they were just across the street
and the Winn-Dixie was pretty shitty but
it was like passable the Food Lion was
like super shitty but like sometimes
you'd go over there and like because
sometimes they had cheaper [ __ ] so you
always had to like kind of check but to
be talking about Publix there Rebecca
said I so miss Publix and Winn-Dixie
even Walmart because we had nice looking
Walmart stores at uh Indy Atlantic Aldi
in Germany and Australia are fancy but
in the US and other Euro countries is a
little trashy yeah I think like Aldi
here it depends on where you are I mean
Aldi the one that we used to go to by
our old house was I don't know if I'd
call it trashy necessarily but
I don't know was it what the Aldi by our
old house no I didn't think it was true
it was just small small I mean it was
really small but but they had good deals
on [ __ ] like considering you could find
good deals on and it was all you kind of
European products
that were kind of generic and or or uh
all de labeled but the quality is good
call it the quality yeah you couldn't
find the same things consistently which
I think was like the main thing but in a
way that's kind of cool like but that's
why you'd have to go to like a couple
different places and Trader Joe's was
kind of like that it was never
consistent what was in there and it was
always their own Brands the quality was
good the prices prices were real
reasonable but there was another version
of Trader Joe's it had kind of like an
Island theme
but maybe Trader Joe's had an Island
theme yeah I think it does there was I
thought there were two different
versions of that some people are really
into like Trader Joe's branded stuff
like some like um what's the one thing
that like a lot of people really like
like some of their Indian food yeah that
comes in like and some of their like uh
kind of like Asian food like you know
sesame chicken or whatever like a lot of
people say that's good and like some of
the like peanut butter cups and [ __ ]
like that you never if you went to a
place like Trader Trader Joe's it was
kind of like kind of like Aldi's you
went in there just to see what they had
yeah and you'd find like whoa look at
this and then you'd buy it yeah never
really consistent you like if I got a
bunch of [ __ ] exotic Jam but it was
fun yeah but it was good stuff it was
[ __ ] they were trying to kind of get rid
of but it was all store branded
um or a lot of it was or you know like
wow look at this man [ __ ]
pepperoni
and then you know sliced pepperoni for
pizza
you know vacuum packed you know and and
and it's you know half the price the
other [ __ ] it looks good and you take it
home and you're like oh yeah this is
great you know it's just [ __ ] like that
you know yeah that's kind of the place
that you go just to like to see what
they got see what they had yeah like as
far as like snacks big jars of damn you
know some kind of Curry
[ __ ] preserves that was like you know
yeah you know
it's Curry pineapple [ __ ] Jam because
why not because why not
in a big ass jar and they only want two
dollars for it you know just try it out
oh it's good on egg rolls you know [ __ ]
like that you never know you might
discover like some good [ __ ] but I think
that's kind of the only criticism that
I've ever seen of Aldi is that sometimes
you find some [ __ ] in there that's like
amazing and then when you go back like a
month later you can't find it you'll
never run it again you'll never find it
again yeah which I get that but it's
just it's kind of like a wild card you
know put some excitement into your life
yeah what it is what they've lucked into
a supply of something right yeah yeah
give us give us [ __ ] five it's like
they're discontinuing this yeah so
that's what's happening we're gonna sell
it off yeah they're not making it
anymore they're not gonna make it
anymore but yeah give it give us five
tons of it we'll put it in our [ __ ]
own packaging and [ __ ] we'll sell it
up yeah that's what they're doing they
sell it up yeah yeah it works Jeff ER
said all these is great I'm a fan of
three dollar bottles of wine and dollar
snacks yeah that's what I made yeah real
good chocolate and [ __ ] you're not
paying much for it right it's exactly
like we've got some really really good
[ __ ] in there but like I said you can't
if you don't like it too much because
you won't be able to find it yeah you're
only gonna get it a couple times Jeff
yard also said But Publix Fried Chicken
is Untouchable yeah yeah it's good I
mean they're Fried Chicken is super good
and they're sub sandwiches yeah
Exquisite especially especially on that
damn multi-grain bread God damn I love
that [ __ ] multigrain [ __ ] sub
bread going for six bucks you can get a
[ __ ] sub yeah six or seven bucks or
something that big with whatever you
want on it you're starting with whatever
meats and cheeses and then you can put
yeah green peppers yeah yeah no no no no
lettuce put spinach yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah onion
do yeah vinaigrette put some vinaigrette
on there
vinaigrette is really good yeah just
whatever you want and you don't get
anything too wet like don't get the
shredded lettuce you can get it out
it'll get soggy yeah good [ __ ] I
gotta have tomato yeah sorry I don't
know I'm gonna I'm gonna eat it as soon
as I get home so it's okay you can get
the dressing on the side but usually we
skip the dressing and then just like put
it on at home and then we'll be sitting
here with a [ __ ] big old [ __ ] Subs
just [ __ ] gorgeous that was back when
we were fat though well I was back where
if I was sitting there look at each
other across it down
look at each other get started trying to
sell that [ __ ] paper on it
how you doing on yours don't get the
roast beef and swiss cheese well see
it's a good deal because you can get a
foot long but I can only like half of it
at once but then you could save the
other half for later and then like have
a half for lunch and half for dinner
it's a good deal like I said I mean my
favorite one is the multi you got to get
the multigrain bread that's my favorite
and I like the roast beef and swiss you
know and I like having pickles on it and
tomatoes and spinach and
so just a little bit Mayo seven says I'm
looking villainous as [ __ ] right now
yeah you see me when I'm bald man
[ __ ] big ass big ass head [ __ ]
everything's getting [ __ ] big like oh
I'll be doing all that [ __ ] see
doing all that
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
how much time we got uh it's almost
eight almost eight probably getting
ready probably we should knock it off
because in case you are just joining us
we're gonna go out this evening yes so I
need to like start over with all of this
makeup stuff nonsense and that takes a
while you know
um American Military 100 said I owe Rob
Zombie an apology Halloween ends was
worse than the monsters
well was Monsters bad I mean yeah I
can't say that I was tempted to watch it
I did watch the cine Massacre review of
it and he seemed like he was trying to
be positive about it like he seemed like
he liked it but he was just kind of like
well I don't really know what to make of
it
um I don't know like the trailer I saw
the trailer for it and I was like I
think I might hate this but I'm not
entirely sure
um I get that it's kind of like similar
in tone to the original show sort of or
at least Rob Zombie's perception of it
but
I see that it's on it's on Netflix right
I think it's on Netflix and I was like I
was kind of tempted for a second and
then I was like well
I don't know man that's like another
hour and a half that I could be watching
something else so I'm not attacking I'm
just I just wasn't checked about it I
yeah that's what I mean it's like I'm
kind of like at this stage in my life
there are just there are so many
horror movies that I'm excited about
seeing old ones and new ones so many
horror books that I'm excited about
reading old ones and new ones so much
stuff I gotta catch up on that if I'm
just kind of like meh about something I
don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna kick that
to the back of the line maybe I'll
eventually like get to it but
I'm just I'm not gonna rush to see it
you know what I mean because I'll be mad
like if I watch it and it's stupid and
then like I'll be like [ __ ] man 90
minutes I could have spent that like
watching something actually good then
I'll get upset
so right it looks like everybody's
checking out so we might as well finish
shut it down all right so have a good
Friday evening you guys uh we're gonna
go out later on like I said and
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
we'll see you again Sunday evening we'll
be talking about some movie or another I
don't know which one yet because we
haven't watched it so you know we'll see
maybe we'll do our luck I don't know
which I don't get your hopes up I don't
really know it's just like whatever we
decide to watch tomorrow night like
that's kind of what we'll talk about but
yeah thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for your super chats and we'll
see you guys again on Sunday bye